okay so this is episode 1 episode 69
this is episode 69 yes legs I just I
just so realized that I don't have CTR
for what I was trying to build what do
you need I'll make it right now
I read intamin intimate penis CTR that's
why I need a rainbow - CTR yes
inappropriate sculptures I will not make
oh no yo what do you call it a mini jr.
coaster Trek thing
thanks I don't know what I don't really
have something for what I want to wear
clothes oh I could make it it's just so
take whoa I have an idea motorcycle
Roman Park like you could I could I
could as well just used a junior
boomerang CTR and on launch its whoever
gives you [ __ ] anyway these have become
a motorbike if you really want to oh
wait I can just take the junior track
better than that
I can take the PE PCT Pepsi - yeah yeah
I can make a secret out like the Coulomb
coaster is unrealistic do you really
want that yes everybody likes you come :
coasters
Holly II want to teach coke monsters low
quality um suddenly the game is lagging
well that's cute
that would be fraps boss that I use my
computer at the moment being very good
recording system volume you're talking
to yourself you should check that really
quick hang on
alright it's time to make this bad boy
why can't it be that boy a bad boy
okay baby kill it with fire basically
I'm just using the track and then I'll
see you later on what kind
or I'm going to use I can wait this
trike uses friction wheels for the
little so I can use a friction we
launched a picture of what you want I
can do that later on yeah yeah can't
wait to watch this video edit the hell
out of it because let's play episode is
not at all what you want right hey it's
a let's play it's not I'm playing
it's a let's play yeah but the word but
the whole let's play thing is actually
kind of stupid I should have named it
silver at plays roller coaster in three
the only thing is that people are not
going to look for that when they want to
see you I think I let's play does note
please though that's because nerve cube
has like millions of subs yeah I should
do a let's play I do let's why do I tell
you it's Lux trying to actually
basically well convinced me that a
somewhat good okay beside the point stop
flattering to ours to make that took two
hours to make yes
two hours such a sexual buzzer done two
hours well wasted in your life yeah I
was worried that you would hate me for
it
no I'm not that kind of guy right yes I
really want more people to use my custom
culture but nobody does they're like
it's like I make a winged rider just as
the wing right of fat ends guys all
right guys is me again
hi guys silver at night no way
Colt supply that video my channel most
loaded just play it ooh
helix yes helix um no my brother fell
asleep in the basement last night and I
was with his friend and my his friends
like hey do you want to wake him up I'm
like I got a better idea so basically I
got the jet the killer basically I held
the screamer his face he's a very light
saber so write me like when the screen
like went into his face you woke up so
right you should make a unicorn section
of your part shut the [ __ ] up you should
make a rainbow - CTR damn this is a
dilemma
I swear I'm going to take this episode
with the Skype call and I'm going to
just well upload it and people are gonna
be like what the [ __ ] you die in a hole
alright guys I didn't even notice that I
did that all the time
hi guys
confronting me with this like I just
realized something
the EP tracks lag a lot that was about
this was a bad idea it's so funny
there's only one coaster just layout
that I can never get down and that's a
wing writer how's that fine it should be
I think we're actually E&M sit downs or
yes and swell ways into main strata
coasters are easiest because all of the
noobs are making intimate strata
coasters always I made an RMC launch
coaster if that counts that that counts
I wanna say but right now working wait
arrange invert with my CTO which I made
my CTR which I made emphases on me guys
me I have you got any good names for a
train based inverted you're asking me
for names does anyone agree Susie does
anyone have any good names anything wait
silver death no fight no sir much rage
much rage very concerned so annoy many
music so butthurt much Ralph so butthurt
is actually grow mad grammatically
correct so that's there we go
I don't know how to make an aqua tracks
but I made one I want a unicorn CTO I do
thank you
what whoops okay let's test this coaster
oh the camera is kind of [ __ ] up
we extreme like by the way
Oh so what do you do in your free time
like when you're not playing RCT yeah
what do you do when you're not point I'm
not playing rct3 if there is any of that
sound I do sometimes these other things
like make music which anime well
masturbate oh sorry
right you should make more silver at two
videos that's to make random videos
about stuff that doesn't even matter
anyway
this ride isn't too bad it's actually
really bad
the coaster is now right about finished
and next episode I'm going to support it
at a station at some cool buildings in
here and it's we're going to look
wonderful
I hope so till then